a
según el observatorio venezolano de la
violencia el conteo de suicidios en
venezuela los seis primeros meses del
año es de 94 personas la mitad de esta
se quitó la vida entre abril y mayo los
primeros meses de la cuarentena
adolescentes entre 12 y 17 años adultos
entre 30 y 65 años representan el mayor
grupo el número de hombres suicidas es 4
veces mayor al de las mujeres las causas
principales se le atribuyen a la crisis
actual que vive el país seguidos por
trastornos depresivos y también por
problemas emocionales y de pareja
algunos organismos no gubernamentales
señalan que las cifras de suicidio en
venezuela se han incrementado en un 150
por ciento los últimos tres años desde
el año 2012 es el gobierno no da números
oficiales el venezolano se ha
caracterizado siempre por ser una
persona alegre de hecho al principio de
la década del 2000 el país punteaba
entre los índices globales de felicidad
pero en los últimos siete años tras la
agudización de la crisis social
estrés y la depresión han ganado terreno
[Música]
aquí en el reino unido- se duplicaron
los casos de depresión durante la
pandemia de kobe 19 la oficina nacional
de estadísticas reveló que uno de cada
cinco adultos sufrió algún tipo de
depresión esto representa un aumento de
100 por ciento en relación con los meses
previos a la pandemia el grupo más
vulnerable fue el de las mujeres entre
los 16 y 39 años de edad que
experimentaron algún problema económico
o sufren de alguna discapacidad el 85%
de los encuestados señaló que sufrió
algún tipo de depresión durante los
meses de confinamiento además las líneas
de ayuda a las personas con depresión
registraron un aumento de 200 por ciento
en el número de llamadas de auxilio
durante el confinamiento los expertos
aseguran que el verdadero impacto sobre
la salud mental se evaluará en los meses
y años por venir
[Música]
en eeuu las cifras de suicidio han
registrado récord desde 1941 de acuerdo
a diversas agencias de salud del país
hay dos razones principales la primera
es el distanciamiento social en medio de
esta pandemia que ha generado a más
hospitalizaciones consultas
psiquiátricas entre otros temas
relacionados con salud pero también el
segundo tema más importante que influye
en este incremento de suicidios es el
desempleo más de 40 millones de personas
han perdido sus trabajos han pedido
subsidios de desempleo sin contar con
los cientos de miles de personas que han
perdido a sus familiares por este virus
y no se han podido despedir de ellos
[Música]